[Narrator] The particle filter that you're going to program
maintains a set of 1000 random guesses as to where the robot might be.
Now, I'm not going to draw 1000 dots here,
but let me explain how each of these dots looks like.
Each of these dots is a vector which contains an X coordinate,
in this case 38.2, a Y coordinate 12.4,
and a heading direction of 0.1,
which is the angle at which the robot points relative to the X axis.
So, this robot moves forward, it will move slightly upwards.
In fact, now a code--every time you call the function robot
and assign it say to a particle,
here the [i] particle,
these elements p[i]x, y, and orientation,
which is the same as heading,
are initialized at random.
So, to make a particle set of 1000 particles
what you have to program is a simple piece of code that assigns 1000 of those to a list.
So, let's do this; let me set N=1000 for 1000 particles.
Here's my initial set of particles; it's going to be an empty list,
and I want you to fill in some code
after which we have 1000 particles assigned to this vector over here.
So, when I print the length of this thing
I will get 1000 instead of 0.